news daily from science mission the
neurovascular in it is made up of
vessels smooth muscle cells under the
control of autonomic neurons and all are
required to maintain heart rate
breathing blood flow digestion etc but
the mechanism of its formation is not
well understood the researcher
discovered that endothelial cells
secrete nitric oxide by the smooth
muscle cells use the protein teka Darren
to interact with the neural crest
specialized embryonic cells that give
rise to portion of the nervous system
and other organs next female mosquitoes
feast on human blood and transmitted
diseases like dang yellow fever etc now
the researchers have identified a gene
called next in male mosquitoes cloned it
and when injected into female mosquitoes
change them into male with male
reproductive organs changing female to
male mosquitoes may be a good strategy
to control female mosquito population
and ready use disease outbreak for more
details visit us at www.hsn calm and
science mission facebook page thanks for
watching